I don't subscribe to the fact that you
have to act serious to be taken
seriously I'm getting ready to sign this
contract can you help me look through it
and give me your thoughts and he only
wrote back was dear Sarah no sane person
would sign this love dad growing up my
dad used to encourage my brother and me
to fail I just moved out of my mother's
house I was 27 years old and I was
probably dating a loser at the time so
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use humor to your advantage I know
that as part of the spanks training boot
camp one of the mandatory learning
modules is comedy that every employee
has to go through so why is that
important I want it I didn't understand
why why everybody was so serious so I
thought you know what I don't subscribe
to the fact that you have to act serious
to be taken seriously and I like to
laugh at myself I you know I looked when
I worked in corporate America for a long
time and everybody was super uptight and
super serious there was no humor and
there was no levity and then everybody
at like 5:00 o'clock became ragingly
hilarious it's like what what's going on
like you know and so the alcohol will
probably help you know but but anyway I
I wanted to to use humor and I love to
do that in the workplace and yes we have
a boot camp at spanks a training boot
camp when you come on board and one of
the modules is doing stand-up comedy and
I've used the comedic stuff that I did
in my marketing I mean I wrote don't
worry we've got your butt covered right
on my package when I first started in
2000 which was not very common to do
especially taking it to the
neiman-marcus to sell it
I named my company Spanx which was you
know made people laugh and believe it or
not it was very shocking at the time
that I named the company Spanx they
actually had people hang up on me often
I would call them and say hi I'm Sara
from Spanx and then they'd hang up and
I'd call back and I go I'm serious I'm a
real company and my company's called
spinning and they go oh oh I thought you
were prank calling me so and then you
know naming my products I broke into the
world's most boring category I mean can
we talk about shapewear who wants to
talk about shapewear and undergarments
but it was I named it power panties you
know I started naming all my products
and it made people laugh and it gave so
much energy and then all of a sudden you
had Gwyneth Paltrow and Julia Roberts
flashing their Spanx on red carpets and
saying I'm wearing Spanx like all these
celebrities and I think it's because I
chose to do humor and people wanted to
participate in that there was energy
around that so so I use it in every
aspect of of the marketing
I use humor to turn around a situation
when I'm bombing it it might give me a
second chance when I cold called to cell
fax machines door-to-door for seven
years I learned very quickly that if I
could make somebody laugh or smile I'd
get another 30 seconds before they'd
slam the door in my face there's just
it's helps you move through pain it's
it's it's a wonderful tool also if you
want to learn from other successful
women entrepreneurs check out my 2:54
girlboss series it's free the link to
join is in the description below when I
was selling copiers door-to-door I had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like from day one I just I
never tried to hide that I was the girl
in my apartment with the red backpack
remember to be smart with your ideas
when I first created the idea for Spanx
I didn't tell a soul for one year and
the reason I didn't do that is because
ideas are the most vulnerable in their
infancy and the moment you have an idea
it's human nature to turn to your
husband your wife your co-worker and
tell them your idea and out of love and
concern oftentimes people will tell you
the two or three things that they think
maybe you should consider and it stops
people a lot of times often right in
their tracks so by not telling anybody
my idea for one year I left ego out of
it and I didn't have to spend the time
defending my idea or explaining my idea
I spent all the time pursuing my idea
rule number three believe in your idea I
had never taken a business class I'd
never worked in fashion or retail and I
had $5,000 in savings I just moved out
of my mother's house I was 27 years old
and I was probably dating a loser at the
time so there you have it there I was
and I you know wanted to wear these
pants I didn't know where to go so I
decided I've got to get this made I went
on the internet and I started looking up
hosiery mills and I went to a website
called Thomas registry dot-com which
lists all manufacturers in the United
States now it's called Thomas net but
they listed it for me and lucky for me
most of the hosiery manufacturers are in
North Carolina while I was in Atlanta
at the time so I started picking up the
phone and calling all these
manufacturers and introducing myself
over the phone and I I just I couldn't
get the right person on the phone people
kept transferring me around I mean I
imagine on the other end of the line
them saying you know here there's a girl
online so she's gonna transform her own
but like which department am I supposed
to send her to everyone kept either
hanging up on me saying no thanks it's
not a good idea so I believed in my own
idea enough though that I realized okay
I want to patent this I may be having
some difficulty right now getting
someone to help me make the idea but I
want to protect it so I went and looked
up on the internet martindale-hubbell
which is a website that lists attorneys
and they will tell you the ranking and
you know sort of the rating next to them
I started looking for a female patent
attorney in the state of Georgia and I
couldn't find one so I called the
Georgia Chamber of Commerce and I
introduced myself said I'm looking for a
female patent attorney and they told me
that there actually was not a female
patent attorney in the state of Georgia
at the time so I said okay I got it I'm
gonna go describe this to a man and
we'll see what happens and I went on the
website I picked three different law
firms I cold call to each law firm I put
on my nicest suit from selling fax
machines that I had I had my lucky red
backpack that was with me the entire
journey of Spanx and I went and met with
them well they all quoted me between
three and five thousand dollars to
patent it and I had five thousand
dollars set aside in my savings to do
this so I decided to patent it myself
well the attorney that ended up helping
me at the very end of this process he
admitted to me that when I came to him
with the idea that he thought my idea
was so bad when I met with them that he
actually thought I had been sent by
candid camera
which completely makes perfect sense
because I was as I was sitting in the
room explaining it to him he kept
looking around the room and he later
said to me he said Sarah I really have
to tell you either thought you were sent
by candid camera or that I was being
pranked by some of my guy friends
because you know you whipped out the
pantyhose you're showing me the crotch
and where you cut these and how you're
gonna change the world and he's like I
wasn't used to that rule number four
embarrass yourself I've said that you
try to go out of your way to embarrass
yourself on a regular basis why is that
well I'm I'm curious about the things
that hold power over us and one of the
big fears is fear of embarrassment we
all have that we have fear of failure so
I'm always working on these things that
I feel like might hold me back and so if
I embarrass myself then it loses its
power over me and especially if
embarrassing myself at times becomes the
goal then it feels like I don't know
it's like I'm playing my I'm like
playing my own head games with myself on
that but like one example of
embarrassing myself is you know I joined
Instagram and I joined F feel like I
might be the last one on the planet to
have joined it was about a year ago and
my team is like Joey we'd Instagram you
got to do it you got to put yourself out
there and I was nervous I wasn't sure
like I don't know and the day that I
joined I happened to be flying to New
York on business and I was at the
Atlanta Airport and so I was like I'm
gonna go around the airport and
personally ask people to follow me and
it was so embarrassing and I was
mortified and I was embarrassing myself
and I posted the whole video it's like
my first post on Instagram is me cuz I'm
like how does this work how do you get
followers so I was around you know
Jackson Hartfield Airport and I even
like stood up in the video I'm filming
myself and I make an announcement at my
gate I'm like excuse me I'm Sara Blakely
and I just joined Instagram today will
you follow me and literally I feel like
that's not one person looks about
thoroughly
I was like thank you thank you I was
going to ask if it worked any more
followers rule number five go against
the grain
Blakely has gone against the grain from
day one when Richard Branson came out
and announced that he was doing a
version of a reality show but he was
looking for 18 entrepreneurs that would
travel the world with him and do a
business challenge in different parts of
the world and I you know applied for it
and my lawyers begged me not to do it
begged me not to do it and I actually
took the contract it was a 27 page
contract and I emailed it to my dad
who's a lawyer and I said dad you know
I'm getting ready to sign this contract
can you help me look through it and give
me your thoughts and he only wrote back
was dear Sarah no sane person would sign
this love dad and you did it in all you
wrote so yes and you signed it I signed
it so my dad you know it's like rolled
his eyes there she goes rule number six
be persistent I call Neiman Marcus
around the corner of my apartment in
Atlanta and I said hi this is Sarah I've
got a product I want to come show you
and the lady kind of laughed and said
well we have a buying office I'm nots in
Dallas okay so I hung up and I called
and called the buyer and from my cold
calling days I knew I'm not gonna leave
a message I'm gonna keep calling until
this woman answers the phone so the
second chance of their phone I took a
very deep breath I was so scared and I
said hi this is Sara Blakely and I've
invented something that's gonna
completely change the way all of your
customers wear clothes and I'll fly to
see you if you'll give me five minutes
and she just kind of took a pause and
she goes well where do you live
I said Atlanta she goes alright if
you're willing to fly here I'll give you
10 10 to 15 minutes so well jumped on a
plane and I went to the Neiman Marcus
headquarters before I went I was you
know my few friends I had my lucky red
backpack they stopped me in my tracks
I had my closest friends they go Sarah
please they were pleading with me please
don't bring that red backpack to the
Neiman Marcus headquarters I mean this
was my old backpack from college it was
just dirty and you know they said do
anything you can't bring that red
backpack I mean if you need to go buy a
Prada bag return it the next day I mean
whatever you need to do but don't bring
that red backpack well I took a very
deep breath I said you know what this is
my good luck charm I got to bring it so
they're off I went with the ziplock bag
in the pack the backpack the color copy
of the packaging I'm went to the Neiman
Marcus headquarters I'm sitting in front
of this buyer that was the most
impeccably dressed woman I'd ever seen
in my life I mean even her pen matched
her outfit I was just and I was shaking
I had my red backpack on the floor and I
started going into my spiel and I was I
knew I wasn't really making a ton of
sense and so halfway through it I go you
know what you just have to come with me
the bathroom just like excuse me I go I
know I know it's a little weird but just
please come with me to the bathroom I'm
gonna do my own before-and-after for you
and then you'll get it so we walk down
the hallway I mean in total silence I'm
like I can't believe this I go into the
stall I have on the white pants that
cause me to invent it I come out with
the Spanx on I turn around I just shown
her what it looked like without the
Spanx on and she took a step back and
she goes I get it
and then she goes it's brilliant and
then she said I'm gonna give you a shot
I'm gonna put you in seven stores rule
number seven be vulnerable I love the
idea of leaders and CEOs showing
vulnerabilities and showing the ups and
downs and you know I just I just don't
really subscribe in the feeling that I
need to put on any kind of a facade to
be taken seriously as a leader and so
it's like this is my life this is Who I
am I'm a mom of four some days I'm
working it out some days I'm not and and
I think that that that's important rule
number eight visualize the idea a moment
actually happened before the idea
because I had been manifesting and
visualizing a different life for myself
I was selling fax machines door-to-door
and I specifically wrote down in my
journal that I wanted to invent
something that I could sell to millions
of people and I wanted the product to
make people feel good and one day in a
frustrated moment couldn't figure out
what to wear under my white pants like
so many women I cut the feed out of
control top pantyhose and threw them on
under the pants and they worked
perfectly they they created the perfect
canvas they didn't leave any lines like
you know smooths everything out but they
rolled up my legs all night and so I
said you know this I got to figure out
how to make this stop comfortably below
the knee and create a whole new type of
undergarment for women that's was in
between traditional underwear that we
had to choose from and the heavy-duty
shapers girdles Nemer nine fail growing
up my dad used to encourage my brother
and me to fail and he would ask us at
the dinner table what we had failed at
that week and if we didn't have
something to tell him he would actually
be disappointed and I didn't realize it
at the time but he was just redefining
failure for me failure became about not
try
not the outcome going through life the
only failure that I ever feel that I've
had is if I don't try so that was a real
gift that he gave me and rule number 10
the last 24 very special bonus clip is
grow organically
I just wanted Oprah I had this product I
felt that it was a you know I was on to
something I needed to build a team I
needed some help so my boyfriend who was
the health care consultant he left his
job and he started helping me do all the
fulfillment
he said you got you you know I'd
semi-trucks pulling up twice a week to
my apartment in Atlanta and I was doing
all the shipping at night and he really
started helping me do the fulfillment
and we were in the back room we ended I
ended up starting the headquarters in my
best friend's bedroom she had moved out
and I we set up two cardboard tables in
the beginning and people used to call
and say I need to speak to shipping and
handling and we'd always say please hold
buy transfer you
then I then I then I went for a walk
with a friend to get a bagel and I'd
given her one of my prototypes and the
entire walk to get the bagel she all she
did was tell me how much she loved it by
the end of the walk I looked at her and
I said do you want to be my head of PR
she's like well I don't know anything
about PR I go I don't either I've been
calling these radio stations and
magazines and circling people's names
and newspapers and I think you could do
it just as good as I could if not better
you seem to really love the product so
she immediately came on board and
started doing that and then the third
person that joined my team was someone
that I was looking for an assistant
because at that time I was doing
everything and also trying to coordinate
my travel and it just got so crazy so
quickly so this woman Joo didya who had
been an interior designer came on board
to be my assistant and after two weeks
in my apartment I came home one day and
I looked at her and I said do you want
to be my head of product development she
looked at me she goes I don't know
anything about pantyhose or shapers I go
I don't either it's perfect now I've got
a special bonus clip from Sara that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching the video to take an action
here we go question number one what gold
can you spend the next three minutes
visualizing it working number two where
can you be more vulnerable in your
business and number three what can you
do daily to help you believe in your
idea and if you like this video and will
take action after watching it give me a
hashtag believe down the comments as
well what keeps you so unbelievably
grounded amid all your resounding
success I I feel like success just makes
you more of who you already were I feel
like money and success just does that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are people you know people
always ask you that and I'm like I don't
know who else to be I mean I am Who I am
so the money the success and so I like
to say if you were a jerk before you got
really successful and a lot of money you
should you become a bigger jerk usually
and if
you were insecure you'll become more
insecure if you were nice should become
nicer if you were generous should become
more generous it's literally just a
magnifying glass
if you want 10 more rules from sera
check out the last top 10 I made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
and I'm a terrible test taker after I
basically bombed the LSAT I hate tried
out at Disney World to be goofy
[Music]